[Applause]
first ones fine I think yeah
your ass looks incredible I did keep one
of the blue dresses I don't wear the
blue Jetta see but I did take it huh
home and have it because I was like I
gotta keep this there's three blue
dresses because in season one Adam did
have a stunt double when they were at
the restaurant where Alana goes into
anaphylactic shock in peri gilpin when
she came on to our show Abby's mom she
had to wear the dress we couldn't get
any more electric-blue had gone out of
fashion but we were very fortunate and
Perry slipped right into the dress that
sort of acts as the Traveling Pants
everyone's kind of been able to get into
it except for bevor is that one time in
the cold open season three I don't wear
it I don't wear it
all right you took my wig home to wear
it I don't wear a blue dress
[Music]